okay so good morning everybody thanks
for coming today
my colleague Chris Hanna Steiner is here
and me I am Francis call Ted we want to
talk to you some things about how to
improve your big data application by
using techniques that are quite
fundamental but I think they are going
to kind of change the panorama how
computations will be made in the future
in my opinion so what is this mean doing
having high performance increasing the
performance on hyper hyper for sorry of
a big data application so in one hand we
meant that we we want to improve
performance okay so compared with other
existing applications like Mumbai or
typically tasks on top of Zaire we want
to get better performance than that and
then on the other hand we want to use or
to compute with compressed data so we
are having a big advantage especially
with other solutions like numpy that
doesn't handle compress data okay so
this is the wall and that allows you of
course to save to save money so how we
are going to achieve this so what we did
is to create an application with several
layers and we like a fine team very
carefully every part of this of this
stack and on the bottom you will see the
storage layer then on top the
multi-dimensional layer computational
layer and finally the API layer so we
are going to explain
bita bit the different layers how they
work but the idea is the idea is that
the storage layer manage the compression
okay so we are like minimizing the
amount of data that the computational
layer is going to handle and then of
course what we need is to fuse as much
as possible the computational step with
the with the with the compression step
so that we reduce
the management of that as much as
possible in the memory buses so before
proceeding further few words about who
we are so I am classes called ed with
onion physicist by training company's
computer scientist by passion and
open-source enthusiast my philosophy
probably most of you will know me
because I am the founder and main
developer of blask on pi tables which
are open source projects hi guys my name
is Christian I well in the past I spent
a good part of my career in the
financial industry building the latency
trading systems and this is basically
where I started to get addicted to
performance and efficiency and I noticed
that in other areas this can be
beneficial as well so now my focus is
when I moved on to apply those
methodologies that I've learned on a
bigger scale where obviously the timings
are a bit different but yeah still the
problems are similar yeah okay back to
you so I will proceed with the lower
parts of the of the layers because I am
more like very very close to the to the
metal in spirit so for the storage layer
what we decided to go is for the for the
blocks library so for those of you that
doesn't know what Loski is it is a it is
a library that is specially meant for
compressing binary data okay
it uses the blocking technique as
explained in different in different
articles in Auerbach website but the
idea is to reduce activity memory as
much as possible and it can achieve
performance because it uses single
instruction multiple data instructions
in different processors like Intel or a
ram or power okay all of these
optimizations has been done for the next
generation of loss which is called Blas
2 and it also leverages multi-threading
capabilities in order to
take advantage of a match scores as
possible see these two things combined
makes blocks really really fast one nice
way to see how Blas can accelerate
computations is this plot which is
described in this blog post that I
encourage you to to rate it but the the
main idea is that when you have to
compute and in this case we are
computing the accumulation of
precipitation in some part of Europe so
this is real data okay
so the combination in a certain region
of Europe and if we are doing the
computation the cumulation without
compression which is the blue bar we can
see that we have like a maximum when we
have with eight threads okay this is
because a threat is kind of maximizing
the throughput to memory because of the
physical architecture architectural
reasons however when we are using
compression we have loss we can see that
compression initially as long as does
the computation we make sense because it
needs to be decompressed and compressed
again but when you throw a good number
of threads at work eventually the the
throughput of using compressed data will
win to the throughput of uncompressed
data so the idea is the tech yeah you
have a question yeah this machine I
think they were 28 but with
hyper-threading is 40 48 yeah I think it
was no this was an AMD so yeah I think
it's 24 so in yeah 24 is 2 yeah exactly
so the take-home message is that don't
blindly think that's just I think
impression to your computations is going
to slow down your computations because
in some situations this this is not
going to be true and in in my opinion
this is I mean the industry is changing
a lot and it's putting more and more
cores and these kind of situations will
be more and more common in the future
and they are happening already
for some kind of computations so another
nice thing about containers in blocks
tool is that we provide different
different containers so when it when
it's called Superchunk and the other
call is called frame so the tuple Chang
is mainly sparse and it is designed to
store data compress data in memory and
then the frame is sequential this is
stored sequentially and it is designed
to either store data in memory or on
disk so depending on your needs you may
want to use one or the other
okay so we have flexibility in this in
that sense also we create a new format
for storing the the compressed data okay
and the new format is essentially the
frame okay so you can you when you see
the frame this is this is a question of
and of course we need a format in order
to interpret what's in every part of the
of the frame so we created a new format
because it is critical for us to find a
way to store and retrieve data
efficiently right so and also it's
important to adopt open open formats in
our opinion for use in the maintenance
burden and also for to facilitate the
adoption more more quickly and blocks to
brings exactly that an efficient way to
open format an efficient on up on an
open format for persistence you can read
more about the format there it's a very
simple one it is based on message pack
and it is around 4 to 5 pages so it's
really really simple especially when
compared with very very complex formulas
like hdf5 or netcdf for example another
feature of a plus 2 is that it adds the
capability of adding meta layers on top
of blocks to containers ok so in the
bottom we have the block container and
then we can add different layers for
adding information about what you are
storing there ok so you can store even
add layers for describing
then the method I mean the
multidimensionality of that
or describing the types or the data or
whatever but then you can on top of this
layer you can put another layer or even
more layers for describing more general
situations like for example describe in
a data that is meant for storing data
for microscopy or machine learning or
financial data for example whatever so
this is very nice because it allows to
create like applications that build on
top of existing layers so you don't need
to add your data layers by yourself one
of the layers that you are seeing there
it's called Kotova and this is what I am
going to describe but this is easily
alliant of a block to that allows you to
describe multi-dimensional data
so what's Kotova so quatre it's an open
source C library but also a format that
allows to store large multi-dimensional
data chant and compress data sets so
that can be stored either in memory or
on disk but the API fought for handle
both versions is is the same
incorporation is kondal transparently
for the user by leveraging the the block
2 library so the user is not really
aware that the data is compressed
because he just asked for data analyzed
is compressed and the compressed
transparently for the user so the katana
metal is actually very simple when you
when you store it so it is just a few
bytes describing the number of
dimensions that you want to store in
this in this container then the the
array for for the dimensions of what you
are storing and then another array for
the partition dimensions which is the
same concept that chunks in is df5 or
ORS are for describing the the
dimensionality for every chunk in the in
the data set ok
of course this mode this meta layer can
be modified so that the shapes can be
updated and that means that we can
resize erase we can ring them or we can
enlarge them
you can find more information about this
here and Kotova is essentially meant I
mean
Katella is not meant to to be used like
in the cloud database moment to be used
as a container for data that is in
memory or maybe data that is stored in
very far solid-state disk we fine-tune
Kotova quite a lot to be very very
efficient in these two layers and for us
these two layers memory and solid-state
disk are kind are part of the memory
storage hierarchy in modern CPUs also
Kotova brings powerful slicing
capabilities so when you have a
multi-dimensional array you want to
access data from this and we provide
machinery the machinery for retrieving
the data so in this data set we see that
the small cubes are what is called the
partitions or chunks okay so when you
ask for the chunks that are in yellow
Katella is going to figure out which
where are these chunks located and they
will catalog will extract them will
decompress them I will hand out the data
for you okay so as I am saying that
arise about multidimensionality about
also about chunking and most of you that
are familiar with with handling chunk
data you must know how critical is
choosing the chunk size of the the
different sizes for the different shapes
of the of the partitions okay so for
dojo don't you that are not familiar
with chunking
let me put an example of how critical
chunking could be so let's suppose that
we have a small or a data set that is
stored this is some 2-dimensional matrix
and the chance are the lines in in in
yellow and we want to access let's
suppose that we want to access to this
role okay so what's going to do Kotova
or other chunk storage is to retrieve
this Chang and that's all the other
chance we may not
touched so this is very featured in this
case okay but what happens when we want
to access the data in the column axis is
the term at the roll axis we need to
attach every chunk right and as a
consequence you we need to read the
whole matrix even if we want only one
single one single block one single
column okay so maybe if we want to
provide like better access in in X x
axis and y axis maybe a better
partitioning will be to create these
squads okay so make the the chance as a
square that possible so that if we want
to access these values again
we only have to decompress only fortune
three chunks not the rest of them only
we want to access the column we all need
to do the compress again only three
channels make sense so of course when we
are going to deal with complex data we
need to to use chunk data because we
don't want to decompress everything in
order to access one single element but
on the other hand this code this
chunking capability is also providing as
a way to fine tune the pattern access
for our datasets okay so a brief
comparison against well-known Chang
containers like SDF I fours are so
Kotova supports most of the things
except that terrorize not hierarchical
so typically you store one data set
where per container if you want a
hierarchy you may want to use a file
system for example it is not yet mature
I mean we are developing it probably I
mean the format is completely
established but we still need to make it
available in production it's already in
beta and one of the distinctive
distinctive features is that for the
memory version we support both the
sequential format and also this part
format so depending on your application
you may want to use one or another okay
so in the
most part we were we are going to show
you why this is useful when you are
accessing data okay so I will hand out
now to Christian about the computational
layer exactly so yeah I will talk a bit
about the computational layer because
it's great if we can basically extract
state and store data very efficiently in
memory but I think most of us what we
really want to do is actually compute
something and I'm as you already can see
here from this layer we're gonna make
heavy use of existing technology in
order to be efficient and when we talk
about computations in this case what
what we mean is mostly expressions
because like that a single operation is
is usually not that not that common and
more common is that you have like a
series or a chain of of different
operations that you want to apply to
your data and so that's why we focus on
the expressions and another so
Franchesca already introduced this
concept of the of chunks and this is
going to be crucial here as well because
when we evaluate the expressions what
happens is actually that we're gonna
operate on a chunk by chunk basis and we
will make sure that those chunks are
small and fit in the in the CPU caches
so that we can optimize it properly we
gonna do this basically by compiling the
expressions with the help of LLVM which
is a quite well known compiler toolkit
that is also used in the Python
community for example for number maybe
other applications that I'm not aware of
and and what it's useful for is
basically to make sure that when we have
large expressions that that we can avoid
temporaries that we confuse the loops of
the operations itself and one very nice
feature as well
that a user basically can write like a
custom operator in Python that then will
be compiled to LLVM ir and in the end
machine code that then can be applied
together with with expression also we
will make use of the well-known Intel
libraries for math functions that are
also used by if you install the combi
editions by numpy and in sci-fi and so
that was basically the summary so if we
get back to the to the benchmarks that
that francesca's shown in the beginning
it's always good to show a bit the
environment where the where those
benchmarks have been created and the
test data that we have used so the the
benchmark has been have have been
executed on Azure on a computer
optimized vm it's for CPU cores eight
virtual CPUs and the test data set is
what run czesc already said is a
precipitation time series state from
Central Europe and the whole dataset is
22 gigabyte on disk which gives you this
discrete as indicated below and if you
go to the first benchmark which is
basically extracting data you can see
that our efforts are still working
progress because here in this use case
for example so R and n task is slightly
more efficient then then using our ad
technology but it's a very small it's a
difference and it will be amortized by
the gains that you have from the
computational layer but I think it's
it's fair to say that it's still working
progress and so what's being done here
is we create like a smaller data set
from this speaker 22 gigabyte
to set this on disk that we're gonna use
in order to do the computations but as
you can see for example hdf5 and tasks
is pretty inefficient if you if you
compare it with with SAR and an tasks or
with with our solution so when we come
to the computations again so the what
you can see here as an example is this
is this expression with that
transcendent involving transcendental
functions and constants and what we can
see here is that here our solution would
really shine even if you compare it to
two numpy which operates entirely in
memory so as you can see I mean it uses
a factor more memory obviously because
it's not compressed and yet it is this
lower so this is due to the effects that
or a lot of different effects but that
that ranchers can myself have I've tried
to explain you have a question now or
you wanna this is using multiple this
using all the four CPU cores that I have
so here yes I mean yeah tricky question
I would say I mean even the scenes in
order to evaluate the sine and the
cosine I think I L can use also multiple
processors right okay so maybe if you
wanna discuss more of that we can do
that in the question and answer section
so now completing this stack so what we
need because we were only talking about
C code so far basically right I mean all
these layers upper are based on a on a
see kernel and what we really want to
have is an API for the for the end users
and we also have that
specially for this conference report in
Python which is what Francesca is going
to show you in a second
so just to recap quickly so the our
stack the whole thing is called iron
array which is a see libraries with
wrappers for Python and Java which can
perform complex computations and
compressed containers and Francesca
already introduced kaptara which is this
middle layer that provides the the
multi-dimensional container with that I
hand over back to Francesca demo yeah so
I was going to show you some
demonstrations both about Kotova which
is the library for the multi
multidimensionality we created for that
a binder from their service so you just
can click here and you can do it
yourself if you want so it takes a while
to create that but you just need to go
to the Catawba repository especially in
the dekat for pi cut for pi is the
wrapper the Python wrapper for for
Kotova so I told you cutter bytes is
made in pure C and cut for pi is the
satin layer on top of of keturah okay so
this is this has been loaded already so
let's just start just to have an idea
how the API works so first of all we
need to import platform I donno so numpy
typically because Katara cut for PI of
courses is optimized for interacting
with numpy so in order to create what we
call an empire array we first we are
going to create a natural numpy array
and then in order to get an MP array
which is an object from from run code
for pi we have different ways to do it
the first one is just yours from number
let me use the font of it it's better to
read okay so this is the first way to do
it it's very fast then another way is to
just create the container and then start
to fill it like chain by chunk okay so
for that we implement small it array an
iterator that is this meant exactly for
creating compressed data containers and
then with that we can feel chance of
this a it is a new PI array and we can
feel the different chunks for the for
the destination okay so this is going to
be useful when for example you're
creating data that I says that are
bigger than memory and you cannot afford
to create the new Empire very first and
finally we can create also just for a
genetic buffer okay we can create the
container specify in the shape of course
and I specify in the type data type that
we are going to use this these are the
different ways to create an MP array and
also an interesting thing is that during
this process we haven't specified the
partition size what so what happened
with with the partition size or the
chunk size so we put some kind of
intelligent algorithm in order to
compute like a reasonable chunk size for
people to use okay so in this case we
are asking which is the partition size
that has been completed and the
partition size is 26 by 5000 so
typically what this algorithm does is to
to favor the way how the layout is
stored in in numpy because most of the
people want to optimize the layout for
numpy data past the data access patterns
but they are allowed also to add for
example a P shape here another another
parameter and specify of course the the
partition size that they want
now we also provide a regenerator for
for for the the arrays so in this case
it is called it'll read as easily it it
is returning the block which is a non PI
Araya for for the partition or for the
blood and then an in for an info part
that is just named tupple that is
providing some meta information about
the position of the of the chunk that is
going to be returned so if we if we run
that we can see that everything has done
a very a very good round-trip because we
are comparing the different uh slices in
the numpy array with the blocks that are
being returned by this iterator which is
a stored in the B 3 which is the catawba
new NP array okay make sense so of
course we can also get an a slice which
is the essential part of Kotova gatina
slices very efficiently and we ask for
some a slice we are going to get a new
PI array which is the spec technique for
for Python users and finally I'm going
to show how to serialize a Kotova and P
array so the typical way to do it is to
to build a new container here for
example and then once we have this
container we can use this to s frame
which is the name for creating a serial
frame a frame that can be sent to
another machines it's kind of a bytes or
stored on disk or whatever okay so this
is very simple to do whoever by default
when we create MP array I told you that
block supports two kinds of containers
okay the sparse container and the the
serialize container which is called the
frame of course converting from by
default
this is going to create a sparse
container because it's more efficient
for for in memory in memory containers
but we can also specify that we want to
a store to create the the situ this is
going to be stored in a sequential frame
not in a sparse frame but in a
sequential one so what's the advantage
of creating on a sequential one so that
when the main advantage is that we when
we create this the serial frame for an
existing frame in memory this is going
to be like memory no memory copies
involved so let's see how it works so we
see that the time for creating a
sterilised array is much smaller here
than here because here a conversion is
been is been done and here no conversion
and no copies are done at all which is
very very interesting and finally you
can also persist that I believe very
easily also just passing the final name
here and you are persisting when you're
getting the the frames or the the
containers you can specify the data
sorry yeah
not yet but it is planned yes we idea is
to create a fingerprint at the end of
the of the container so that you can
make sure that all the all the data is
is be safely stored and you can you can
check that that doesn't have any any
issues okay yeah with that let's move
with night on array example so for I
don't know rain and would you read this
yeah yeah so here we are importing our
array and then we are specifying
different parameters for we are using
compression right so this is specifying
the kind of codecs that block is going
to use so block can use different meta
different codecs in this case we are
going to use a set for which is one of
the fastest codecs available then
compression level five the number of
threads can be specified as well and
also we are going to specify the number
of slices that we are going to retrieve
for them for a big data set and we are
storing all this the compression
parameters in a dictionary here so these
are going to be this prescience that we
are going to compute like this with
transcendental functions like sine and
cosine and this just automatically
spray-shun
with several appearance
and then our data set is the tune net 22
[ __ ] bytes that we were referring to
and it is stored in this in this
directory here okay and it is in format
I run array essentially it is brusque
with a metal layer of iron array this is
what it is meta layer of Kotova and then
a metal yeah I don't know ray so if you
look at that you can you have seen you
can see that the data is not right in
memory it's just opened from the disk
and that the data can be can be used to
strike from the disk okay this is also a
nice feature of I don't know ray and
cutter as well so now we are going to
get different a slices from this very
large data set 22 [ __ ] bytes I'm not
going to enter into the detail but
typically I am going to use the same
write iterator than in in Kotova
but the one specific foreigner array
which is going to create a new
appearance block like block then we are
using different random positions in
order to to extract the different uh
slices on disk so from now on we were
creating the new containers in memory
okay because here we are specifying with
this that we are creating the new
containers the slices are we going to be
in memory because in the end I don't
Nara is more meant to do operations
within memory data we are interested in
in operating with compress data in
memory so this is the first a slice
second there lies a third a slice which
are going to to be used as as operands
for this prescience we have different
compression ratios of course because
depending on this light that you are
extracting you get different compression
ratios because that is is not uniform
and then let's go with the computational
part where we we can see that we are
doing the evaluation by instantiating
this x class with some
parameters which are going to to be the
ones that are used to create the the
final result here here the different
flags for the evaluation in this case we
have different ways to do the evaluation
we're going to use the more efficient
the most efficient one here then we bind
the different the different parameters
to different variables in desperation we
compiled expression so this expression
it's if you remember is this one design
okay
and then let's do the operation so in
that case it took around 2 seconds to
perform in an array so everything is
compressed okay in this case even the
output is has been compressed as well
and here here is the comparison with
Mumbai which is doing exactly the same
thing is just creating another another
container for for numpy and we are going
to pass this container here but we are
evaluating exactly the same expression
so let's see how it goes for comparison
so it is five seconds okay so it takes
like twice as much as iron array okay so
this is a first demonstration of call a
fishing can be using compressed
compression not raw so multi-threading
with with our array and then just for
the mother of comparisons we can compile
we can execute the second expression
here which is this one it's going to
take four seconds in this case for our
array and then for Mumbai steak in a
while
so eight seconds again we have like a
factor of two of improvement which is
yeah the thing that we are going after
they must trying to demonstrate yeah the
in the demonstrate that iron array can
can do efficient performance fishing
competiton 'el computations with
compressed data okay so that's mostly
all we still have so thank you we still
have well you can get much more in more
information in this URLs and yeah if you
want to ask anything we are here for
trying to to solve that okay so any
question yeah we are using servicing
compressions yes so you know that's our
and use is using loss behind the scenes
so we are using exactly the same scene
setting of course you know it wouldn't
be fair yeah mm-hmm more questions yeah
[Music]
that means that the change so it arises
procreate in containers and iterate is
just for for iterating on existing
containers and getting chunks of all of
the existing containers one is meant for
creating containers and the other is
meant for accessing containers mm-hmm
yeah yeah
yeah yeah cycle before I weird moment
like to be efficient on in memory memory
compressed data but of course we can
also think on providing some functions
for providing efficient block size or
chunk size for memory that data is based
on disk instead of memory but now I mean
by default what we are doing is to
create a chanc with fits comfortably in
l3 cache so that the operations doesn't
have to I mean the lintel terminate that
of the operations can not doesn't need
to travel into memory but can stay in
the cache of the CPUs for for weather
performance does the
persistent - or is it kind of assumed
you have like no I mean yeah at the
moment at the moment it is like this so
it's using the the operating systems
file interfaces right so it is not
optimized for anything like in writing
to s3 or whatever so it's religious yeah
it depends right let's say in the older
world where you have a distributed file
system but abstracted away by by other
let's say by distributed file system
itself right there it doesn't matter
it's a background it's only if you would
wanted to to implement it yourself by
using s3 then this is not really I mean
then you can do it by yourself but it's
not supported it's not our goal yeah
yeah because our belief is usually then
you have to look at the overall problem
right I called you because if you just
provide such a facility out of the box
then it might or it might try to solve
part of a problem that should have been
solved differently in the first place
at least it's my opinion
sar and obviously dark does have all
these family you know
broader distributed storage engines how
would you kind of describe the
philosophy in I mean this is a whole
stack right we're gonna blossom because
they're uh nope iron array the other
ones more like bizarre using blocks so
here this yeah that's the thing
I mean we're also intending to to kind
of come up with with a with a model for
a larger distributed case but we're not
there yet them that's um that's true
and also well when we when you are
trying to get the most performance out
of that you need to be very careful
about how to merge the compressed data
with the computational layer so I mean
we need to to be careful that we are not
getting data from the cloud because this
is going to kill performance right so
typically this is why we are interested
more in the in the layers that are very
close to the to the to the CPU
exactly that's right that's why I said
it's part of the the overall problem
then that has to be looked at right yeah
so it really depends on the actual
problem that you're trying to solve them
and we cannot provide everything with a
library right so we just provide let's
say one building block and then yeah so
the rest of the problem has to be looked
at independently I would say yeah okay
thank you thank you very much